[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas sûr
madec et vous
[Applaudissements]
pour sauver la planète qui plante un
arbre
il y trop marrant ce mec
bonjour la question évidemment que que
vous posez ces eaux-là la ressemblance
et patrick hivon
c'est pas vrai s'est pas fait c'est
patrick génial quand même un lien de
famille avec raout bah je sais pas c'est
peut-être ma soeur là on est tous les
deux je sais pas tant ce mois
ci arrête tes conneries
arrête tes conneries mais non bien
prêter finir par état
allô bonjour et bienvenue au service
après ventes de darty vous êtes monsieur
je suis jacquouille bien monsieur queen
que puis-je faire pour vous
je vois votre téléviseur a explosé
pouvez vous me dire quel bruit elle
faisait avant l'incident voilà
[Musique]
en effet c'est un bruit caractéristique
c'est un téléviseur thompson
un sony non c'est une marque connue au
moins
un panasonic a très bien monsieur
j'envoie technicien chez vous à quelle
adresse
moi j'ai trouvé ça dans la base de
données
parfait mais si vous avez un instinct
pourrais je vous demander si vous êtes
satisfaits de la qualité de notre
entretien
bonsoir la fuite elle est dans la
cuisine comme je vous ai dit au
téléphone beaucoup plus longtemps depuis
ce matin c'est cool en continu d'accord
ah bah voilà c'est cool vous êtes super
rapide quand même depuis ce matin je me
dis que ça va être galère et où on m'a
dit que c'était un peu galère avec les
premiers mais c'était ça votre 28 et le
robinet qui coule dans la cuisine ce que
je vous ai dit au téléphone oui oui oui
coup il coule tu coules et oui bien sûr
je dois combien du coup
144 je peux vous faire un chèque oui
c'est très bien
et voici merci beaucoup c'est parfait au
revoir